気づいたら思ってエレベーねーどたくさん買ってました
goo
tan
はぁっ
はーいっ様々な戦法を楽しめるようになってきた有業者ねーんっ
ベイルの結構術が増えてきてこんなもっと増えてくれてもかなり楽しいです
いろんな戦略が広がった今カスタム力でもない修道打ち方でもないそう
回転力てみて今回の小西反応シューターでは何かでこちらの
うわぁこちらの拘束ドリルを使ってベイビーで飛ばしていきたいとおもいます
jaja by からでこれ回転力が本当に笑いないスピード朋友速度からもう一気に
すごい回転しますよ
これやばいよあ本当に危ないのでやんないでください露木今回これは何とか使って
ベイブレードちょっとで最高の1秒で4200回転サルコウ拘束ドリルで霊動漫提供
ポッドベイベーと界最強の通りんだろうと思いますヴェイコ
まず考えなきゃいけないのはどうやってますかということで普通にな店が入っている
だけなのでここにベンレートをつけるのはちょっと難しいとそうなるとどうやってます
かがポイントになっていきます作戦その1つに回ってレベル度に向かってこれを直付け
してこのまま
せても回転しているベイベーと時代のスピードを上げますこれけっこうず不安でだから
難しいと思うんだよね誠意って右腕格子
あっ
摂津駅カラオケ
逆回転か実現もゼロからここからスタートしてもこの状態ぴっくりスピードをかけて
ます
生きる気はする
ああ
ええええええ
動きがちょっと作戦を変えましょう今ダメダメだったかというとたぶん
接着して完成はここが子があってた菓子だからスピードはめちゃくちゃ速くなったとし
てもこの話すとにちょっと暗ってなっちゃってそこで減速して結局 p が出なかった
んで次へガムテープを使いますガムテープこの先端に貼ってねここにベイブレードを
くっつけるといい感じいい感じで回転させると多分アムスピード上げて
越前落下しちゃうんでその自然落下するまでにもっ
越前楽せるまでにスピードが上がっているとそうなればも最高速で落下できるんで募集
だと同じ原理ですね落ちるまでに回転力を高めてそのまま
放つそのちょっと拘束ドリルでやってみようと思います
ファー
今重心捉えてなかったなぁ
ああああああ
tar
dj
ココア
さあ
ムリポ次はもうちょっと本気で接着尺 the 具材やベイブレードにつけてここに
くっついて紙テープ何が駄目だったかっていうとバランスがとれなかっ
だから重心がぶれターンでさっきみたいにポロポロって真っすぐをつくることができ
なかったので次は接着剤でちょっと中心を捉えてまっすぐ落としたいと思います
いきますこれでしっかり付けると
ん
このでしっかりつけます完璧ですを食べる真上を取ってるんでこれでちゃんとくっつい
て高速回転させて早すぎて落下すると大回転になると思います
もう来たんじゃないもう一つ
は強いなこれ多分一帯をこれ落ち完璧完璧これはいたさあさあ
すでに本がこれは行ったんでしょもうこれは一発勝負でいきましょう
いきます
ツリー2はまたてブクマれた分成功パターンなんでさすがに防具をつけておきますでは
行きます
ってばんわーシュッっ
あれ
場合は取れなくなっちゃった
3種
支援ちょっと待ってどうしよう
あああのアンサーつけたての頃とかに家とかつけて次でもうほんのすぐ本土もうすぐ
もうすぐスイスがもう今ぐらいまでないんで打ちましょう
もう今売っていいと思うこれであるマルよ
2つたった一つだ来たぞ来たぞ
あー入った